okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel with my
morning coffee
it's not really morning it's like noon i
have sleep issues okay
kind of sick today a little bit a little
bit sick
and
i have a paper due that i keep like
pushing off
guys i don't care about school i don't
care at all like i just
wanna
do youtube that's it
but
in order to procrastinate just a little
bit more i'm going to be doing a morning
coffee chat so what are we talking about
today
you saw the title of the video which i
don't know what it is yet but i'm sure i
made it good
um
i want to talk about something my dad
told me okay
and my dad i always say like he hates
people my dad
he doesn't really have friends not a lot
like he doesn't put
a lot of effort and like emphasis on
friendship
and
my mom was always the one to like
you know like maintain relationships
with people
but
there was a time where there was this
guy from my church i was friends with
okay
and um
i was supposed to go and i
hate it everyone's gonna be like he's a
chad
but i'm gonna tell you a story anyway
um i was supposed to go play basketball
with him one day
and um
we're like going to play
and he just like doesn't show up and it
really pissed me off because
one this man asked me to like learn
about social media or whatever so i
brought like my stuff for him
that he asked me to bring and then he
just didn't come and i'm like sitting
there waiting and it was fine because i
ended up like working out anybody anyway
but it was just like rude and i was like
pissed off because i went out of my way
and i'm bitching about this to my dad
i'm like dad you will not believe what
this man did i did all this and he
didn't show up my dad looks me and he's
like okay who cares
just don't deal with him anymore
and
i'm gonna bring you guys over here
because i'm starting to get a little
parched and
that's my dad's answer to literally
everything like
whenever i tell my dad anything like i'm
like dad i'm approaching the wall
okay who cares
what are you gonna do about it
or i'll be like dad
these comments
did something or whatever and he's like
okay who cares
and the reason being is because
my dad told me he's like hannah because
people may or may not know my first name
is hannah most people's opinions in life
don't matter how many people do you
really deal with because my dad isn't on
social media right so we feel like even
you guys you deal with me you're
watching me you're listening to me
you probably feel like you know me and
you do on some level i put a lot about
myself on the internet but
my dad
doesn't have social media so he realizes
how many people you actually deal with
and
even like
i was kind of nervous when i started
getting on the internet that like you
know people
that i've maybe
had
i don't really wanna
just you know ex-friends or whatever
would
come out or ex-ex-boyfriend or something
would come out and like
you know i don't know say things about
me or whatever nothing crazy but like
just personal information right and my
dad will always say who cares like that
is his answer to everything it's so
annoying as a daughter because you bring
stuff to him and he's like who cares who
cares because at the end of the day he's
right though most people's opinions
don't matter that much like
what what relationships matter in your
life it's like your family your close
family your your friends
and your relationship with your
significant other those are the people
you're gonna deal with day to day
everyone else like their opinions don't
matter
and don't spend time chasing them
because
i mean it's like did one thing if it's
mutual but don't spend time chasing like
people that don't want you
and
the last couple years i'm telling you
i've adopted this mindset like if
someone does me dirty or does me wrong
i take a step back
i just i see them for who they are and i
move accordingly like there's no point
in getting mad there's no point in
getting frustrated because the end of
the day most people you won't deal with
for that long
like i'm in london now most people
i'll know for another maybe six months
and you get to pick who you want to deal
with so
who cares
that's my morning coffee thought i'm
kind of sick so sorry if that was
jumbled okay
but let me know what you guys think in
the comments and let me know what you
want me to talk about next time love you
bye